thank you
[Music]
did you guys hear about the Wendy's
manager who made up a fake employee so
they could pocket extra wages smart I
heard a lot of people do that really is
a genius that's a smart house because
all you have to do is put the person on
your shift and say you saw them all the
time and now per shift or per hour
you're getting yeah you're getting
double paid but then what about the tax
yeah though like the Social Security
yeah who's it getting paid out to paid
out to write that's why they were saying
that's why they were saying it's not
just her it's like payroll would be in
on it too and maybe she's like kicking
them back away yeah but who's it cashing
how do you cash out to a person create
another account another identity you
just hire someone take the check to to
him but like then it's traceable so the
the payments were going to her cash app
account interesting so I guess it's like
paid through cash app
where the [__] is this when he's at yeah
dude damn yeah so the rest they were
paying 19 898 between June 2021 2021 and
May of last year is this person like the
manager they yeah the general manager so
oh yeah so they can just hire a buyer
and then they're like we have this
employee they call them William Bright
then she had him clock in and out
um and kept the scheme up going for over
a year employees are like I don't
remember working with someone called
William Bright but whatever I work at
when you don't give a [__] to talk to
anybody until the police were involved
the crazy thing is that's just Wendy's
but the stories that have come out about
people doing that or knowing of people
doing that was that big businesses where
there's a lot more money than that wow
wow wow like that's just 19k but imagine
like a company for years like a large
that's true and you have a six figure
income and less people that can check
and balance that
that's a lot of money in the [__]
ether it's a good hustle there's uh
another Switcheroo scheme that I know
where people like let's say they come up
from down south like Mexico or whatever
they'll come up they work up here they
make a bunch of money that they are good
with and then they have like a legal
standing citizenship or whatever
they'll leave take that money and then
just tell one of their other friends to
go up hey I still have that identity up
there so like let's say your name is
Jessica or whatever you have another
Jessica come up but then that Jessica is
just another person and they can go get
another job and get paid or whatever
yeah swap socials yeah just keep that
social alive technically and then just
if when you're done with that bring the
next person and the next person in so
the person can keep having a job getting
paid as someone who hires people quite a
bit both of you guys
have you had anybody do something scummy
like this oh I have wonderful employees
like they're so sweet like they care so
much so it's just hard for me to even
think that people can be this shady and
I think like when you're a small
business like this is usually like you
stick it to the man right like the
general manager I'm sticking it to the
man which is like the Wendy's owner
small businesses the man is you so it's
like hard to like you know it's like you
don't always stick it to yourself and
you have so much more good way to stay
humble though yeah I have my team
members like they'll read a Yelp review
and feel bad that like a customer felt
that way about them and it's like some
of their first jobs and then like you
know they're like 17 and they just it's
really a big deal so like they get Pride
from it and I'm the one that's like
chill customers be crazy you know
yeah you know it's funny there's so many
comments on this thing about like well
Wendy's is such a big company they're
not gonna care if it's just 19k but it's
like dude the franchisees being robbed
you [__] [__] and the fact that like
do you think the [__] do you think it's
gonna be even easier for her to get
another job after this
she can't work at a [__] fast food
place now yeah and she was General
managing too so good it's not bad yeah
it's like that was not a good decision
at all they act like she's like uh just
an entry-level cashier like someone that
just started like if it if you're a
general manager even if it's fast food
you're getting paid good and you
probably worked there for 10 years
you're probably at least 30 or 40. what
are you gonna go with like a felony
record that's what I'm saying like it
puts her in a way worse position now
yeah well you got 19k right there you go
over like a year now she got to turn to
hold you off for what a few months yeah
she has to turn to old-fashioned
thieving now yeah
this is what I don't understand is like
when people are mad at I get being angry
at these major corporations that might
be hurting a lot of people in a big
scale right like jumpy is a major
corporation yeah but when you think
about
things like Wendy's
like people that don't understand a
franchise model they don't know that
they're hurting that little family
that saved up the money to like open up
that Wendy's franchise yeah Mr and Mrs
Park yeah and paying the fees people go
people do that thing where they go well
wait Jumpy's got a bunch of locations so
like if I'm stealing straws or whatever
who gives a [__] they're a big company
already yeah they disperse it they have
no idea and I I guess like it's because
like they see things like McDonald's and
then they hear the word franchise and
then they they don't quite understand
what it is but they just think big evil
Corporation and then whatever McDonald's
does that because it's basically the top
franchise right whatever they do that's
[__] up it trickles down to everybody
else who has the same term franchise so
it's like even if we're all friends and
family then we're like less than 10
Stores
um and it's all independent like some of
these people that it's like it's their
first business our franchisees are like
you know what I don't want to have this
corporate job anymore I saved up this
money and I want to be a part of the
team a lot of people join franchises
because they don't want to open a
business from scratch meaning like
maybe people have great ideas but
they're scared to open up a business on
their own so what they'll do is they'll
buy a franchise because there's a model
that works they did the hard work of
like creating a brand having a product
doing all the tests making sure it's
something that people want and they're
like here we're going to teach you the
model but you're trying your money to
open the store and then you're gonna
manage it and run it so that's like a
really good first step for a lot of
people to be their own bosses in
McDonald's case they use hella analytics
too they know where to open them and how
much they'll probably generate it's
crazy but even within the franchise
world there's like small ones like jumi
and then there's big ones like
McDonald's where you need millions in
assets to even qualify to open up a
McDonald's yourself yeah or you have
Chick-fil-A where you need to work for
them for how many years and also like 10
years yeah 10 years to work there too
for a certain amount of time yeah and
you have to be pretty much Christian and
all that stuff but
that's where I think it [__] sucks is
like some people don't know the
difference and they'll take it out on a
small business owner
that's in the same boat as these people
don't know the difference yeah yeah
my buddy Houston working at Chick-fil-A
God I want to say like five years ago
he's a general manager there now and he
says that every time that you they
onboard you you have to burn a pride to
play
you have to stop on a pride for that
during the onboarding anytime you get a
promotion as well right you have to say
the Lord's Prayer that's the initiation
yeah gotta call Everyone by their dead
names
[Laughter]
they do tremend to him I know you're a
[__] him I can see it what do you
want what do you want to eat what kind
of chicken you want you sure that's the
name you want to go with okay all right
you don't really sound like a Susan but
okay
very well for being only open six days a
week dude they're really nice
there's so much nicer than other
employees
is really good too is the only two
places is Chick-fil-A and in and out
employees are really good oh yeah I love
internet employees and go figure the
most Christian groups
hello Christian
yeah it says John 3 16 here
yeah a little more subtle and they're
open on Sunday what do you think in and
out feels how do you how do you think
they feel about gays do you think they
got beef I think they're I think they're
okay with it I like that yeah I don't
know I think they're okay I liked it I
didn't mean to do that I said you would
have done eyebrows any any time I said
anytime I accidentally say a pun just
know that it wasn't on purpose it wasn't
on purpose I don't do puns Anthony
basically like he does the pun and he
sits here and like shits his pants and
like enjoys the warmth please please
don't give me any credit for anything
that I say accidentally that turns out
to be a problem I gave props to
Chick-fil-A for being such a good
business they were able to transcend the
effect of people hating them for
something yeah their product is too good
their service is too good no gay person
anywhere is allowed to eat Chick-fil-A
technically but I know how many people
that do
wait I go there a lot
that's like a [__] like baby back rib
barbecue spots full of Muslims
[Applause]
the food is so good it makes people
break their [__] that's what I'm
saying dude like it's it's it's just too
good of a business overall yeah it's
like Ben Shapiro's in the Barbie movie
yep it's too good it's also too cheap
it's like really cheap yeah Chick-fil-A
it's a good price for what you get every
other breakfast
what do you think happened over the
years to where like there's just this
weird idea about
um service and blue collared work
because most of my experience like
working experience have been in there
I've never really worked corporate ever
so
um
and I never like I just don't get where
like I know we people always joked about
like fast food right working fast food
but then now it's almost like people
think Blue Collar jobs are beneath them
there's like a stigma to it everybody
wants to be well they don't even want to
be corporate anymore right because like
even if you are a white collar worker
they're like oh now you're like
brainwashed whatever and it's like
people want to be their own boss or
freelance or whatever but it's like you
gotta learn how to work if you want to
be a boss too yeah the best lessons are
in the shitties I think so too and guys
that are in
um like blue collar jobs they're
crushing it right now dude bro like
construction Plumbing all that they're
making up HVAC guys I'm so jealous of
them I mean trade workers are [__]
yeah yeah but it's only going to get
better for these guys but it's like
entry-level work is different than like
a trade work you know like if you're
like working one of those no skill jobs
I just have respect for people that are
willing to work at a time where there's
no employees wanting to have any jobs
like when you see a kid working at boba
time or some [__] it's like hey [__]
dope rather than not do anything that's
sick that you want to work I mean like
what what kind of bubble you want what
the [__] is your problem man yeah yeah
they get mad at you like why are you
staring at me they drag their feet to
the [__] thing and they're like what
do you want I just want to let you know
that this is pretty dope yeah they're
like do you want a large or a small
[Laughter]
foreign